we tried a number of things I think the
portals event was clearly this challenge
to Joe and Anthony about this is we've
got it we've got to really get this
right the material that we ultimately
use for that was new material in endgame
and again there are all these events
going on you know there's there's cap
then the wakandans come in then Doctor
Strange appears and then I mean
everybody is and there was a temptation
and we actually explored it to like be
making moves with you know and here yeah
and here's what they're themes come well
it's not you know what it's not even so
much as separate themes as just like you
know marking these entrances they're so
big but they never stopped I mean they
go go go and so where we wound up with
was an approach that really I think the
sensibility was that it was anthemic tap
of course was down and out he was done
for and so that theme somehow had to be
almost celebratory in a certain way it's
like oh my god everyone is coming it's
like the joke you know as is this
everyone or whatever it is there's like
you want more there are no more
basically and so that was the approach
we wound up with and then of course you
know the way they constructed it was
just so great for music because it's
building its building and then of course
caps line you know when he says assemble
you know the music's out and then we
come back in with our Avengers theme
that was something that really evolved
it was tried in with other choreography
if you will you know what are the beats
what are the big moments but that
ultimately wound up to be the spot where
everyone felt like this is this is the
perfect spot and it's it's interesting
because it's a very kind of kinetic
moment I mean everyone's running right
and it's now it's just this big theme
playing we catch up to all of that
action musically a little later but for
this point it's we're just saying pure
Avengers we're back we're all here
you're in a lot of trouble now pal
so yeah it was that it was an evolution